venez nous voir pour la tenir pour la
madone on désire époux mariés oui
l' agence matrimoniale le lieu pour
rencontrer celui ou celle avec qui
partager toute nue japan agence
matrimoniale chercher ce nom de l'
histoire sérieuse surtout dans les
années 60 et 70 à l'époque pas de tender
pas de meetic
mais il y a plus de 1000 agences
matrimoniales dans toute la france avec
des clients de tous âges et de toutes
catégories sociales
cette étudiante en lettres vous êtes
journaliste
j'ai cru bien faire de vous présenter
pour rapprocher deux célibataires
il y a bien sûr le flair de l'agent
matrimoniale mais déjà en 1965 bien
avant les algorithmes d'aujourd'hui les
agences avaient des méthodes très
pointue et âge bois taillé profil
psychologique critères recherchés tout
est codé dans ses fiches perforé une
sorte de carte d'identité amoureuse vous
prenez la carte perforée de mademoiselle
duval et celle de monsieur durand ou les
juxtaposer et si à la lecture par
transparence vous voyez apparaître
beaucoup de points lumineux c'est que
mademoiselle du valais monsieur durand
sont faits l'un pour l'eau
le système va encore plus loin dans les
années 70 il prend en compte les goûts
les hobbies les pratiques sexuelles et
même le fameux tests psychologiques de
l'arbre à ce qui frappe d'abord c'est
son aspect tour manqué souffrent
douloureux coucher toutes les méthodes
sont bonnes car il faut afficher des
résultats pour appâter de nouveaux
clients dans les années 70 les patrons
d'agencés se vante d'être à l'origine de
plusieurs dizaine de mariages chaque
année seraient dans deux trois ans que
vous êtes marié et si vous demande si
vous êtes
qu'est-ce qu'on va à l'issue donc vous
conseiller aux gens qui sont dans mon
cas qui va entendre ma relation de
s'adresser une agence a pas de problème
pas de problème pas de problème vous
savez ma famille on se met toujours
c'est que s'en remettre à une agence
matrimoniale
c'est un budget entre 500 et 1500 francs
pour une année d'adhésion dans les
années 70 et aujourd'hui les agences
existe toujours il y en a environ 570 en
france entre 600 et 3000 euros l'année
d'adhésion le marché résiste malgré
l'essor des api dont les sites de
rencontres virtuelles sont pour moi plus
une bergerie et dans laquelle il y a
beaucoup de loup puisque dans une agence
matrimoniale la sécurité le sérieux
voilà le secret de longévité des agences
matrimoniales
[Musique]